shall we go to our first story oh we're
not even in Astoria or not we're just
we're just making sure makes me see how
much fun we have just talking man in
tears a nurse says she quit her job
after she was asked to work in Accra no
virus I see you without a face mask
America is not prepared and nurses are
not being protected you know when this
story first came I took it seriously I
was like man it's worrisome yeah when
you get nurses and doctors quitting and
there were real nurses quitting not this
you know fake whatever then I mean
things have to fall apart but but there
is good news I mean they're saying that
for New York were nine days away from
the peak in which case things start
chilling out oh that's nice there's
there they're saying what we might start
easing up on restrictions it might we
might actually get the restrictions
lifted much sooner than everyone
realized so it's good news for now yeah
but just because they're seeing like the
amount of daily deaths go down in in New
York doesn't mean it's over if they lift
restrictions then two weeks from now
it'll spike again yeah so doctor foul
she is saying maybe this is the new
normal until we have a vaccine or like
you were saying earlier about like the
the deaths that they're finding in like
apartments are not the only started man
you know you know what is over so what's
really annoying me is there are a lot of
people who are it's clear what they're
trying to insinuate casting doubt upon
what's going on like you know look I've
done this when we talked with the
paddleboarding guy and the beach you got
arrested right and that expert who said
that the virus was in the water and then
kicking up into the air or whatever it's
like oh that was an expert that said
that some marina that's right there's
there's there's literally billions of
viral particles bouncing up in the air
you which is like I wouldn't go to the
beach if you paid me a million dollars I
shut up there's probably billions of
viruses in the water anyway yeah all the
time it's it's not even about that it's
like listen if you don't want people to
go to the beach just to be honest about
it right and then tell them to go home
if they show up anyway yeah but to make
up these ridiculous stories yeah so
Candice Owens who is like a big trump
personality has been tweeting a bunch of
things and one of the things she tweeted
was a story from the New York Times that
said where has the the heart attack and
stroke victims gone right and then she
tweeted doctors around the world are
wondering what's happening to these
patients and and flu and pneumonia
deaths have dropped off the insinuation
that peep
we're making I don't want to I'm gonna
avoid accusing her directly but the
people in the comments were saying like
we're applying to her tweets that these
doctors are taking heart attack deaths
and and calling them coronavirus because
there are these stories popping up where
it's like my grandma in Italy you know
we've talked about those stories and
they're there there are a few stories
that people have highlighted there was a
story of an infant who was in the
hospital for some kind of a procedure
for a month like a very serious you know
and then contracted covin and died and
so people are questioning why that was
labeled as a Copa death I think it's
fair I just you know like like they've
said over and over again it's underlying
conditions which you know so it's
contributing factor there are some
people who are sick who would probably
survive might get it might not lot might
not live right and so they're they're
they're you're labeling it as Cova death
but the other thing is what people don't
realize people in New York and all over
are dying of Crona virus and not being
tested and they're not being labeled
coronavirus yeah so that doesn't make
sense
take them both right if you think
they're over counting some things
they're definitely under Counting other
things so they're they're saying in New
York that if they find a DOA it's like
if they get a call for a wellness check
and there's someone dead and they can't
determine the cause of death they don't
put down his chrono virus so the city is
concerned they're under counting right
you know the - right well let's take a
look at this this nurse right here right
so so I love this because we have this
tweet and just below it we we have
Melissa a two months from now we will
find out this find out this justice
Millette 2.0 fake she got 943 weeks
retweets on April 5th lo and behold on
April 6th Amar's Vera the nurse in the
video clarified her experience on Monday
in a tweet quote we were each assigned
one and ninety five per one kovat
patients room but was not allowed to
wear it outside the room where our own a
ninety-five masks around the nurse's
station or halls which I came prepared
with well all of a sudden that is not
what she said when she was crying all of
a sudden areas very different yeah well
see what you did room she omitted that
they actually gave her a mask and said
use this approved mask we have for you
right and she was like I brought
protection protection and they wouldn't
let me wear it was it like a Mickey
Mouse mask or something was it like am I
right but she said right there that she
was she used her own mask when she's in
the nurses Hall but when you go into the
room with the kovat patient you ask the
kovat mask that they gave you right I
mean so I was crying but here here I
wonder if it's the fault of the media or
her because she admitted to it okay
I was it the next day yeah crying and
what she was saying it has nothing to do
with that's true yeah it was a good
point she she didn't tell the truth and
not really that not only that but she
had quit apparently taking like a hiatus
oka to be an Instagram model or
something that's a story that's been
going around a influencer yes they're
known I saw some pictures and then like
a day or two crack me up and then she
comes back for like a day and then quits
right away so everyone's calling you no
BS on this they say oh I can get some
some real big hits some likes but here's
what's funny about the media CBS just
adds a little tag to the bottom of the
tweet which no one will see yeah and
that's like sufficient for them to say
they corrected it oh yeah whatever
and then what ends up happening is its
conservative sites that pick it up and
start sharing it so now if your so
there's this really funny study that
I've shared and progressives really hate
it it shows that people on the left
liberals typically only get their news
from liberal sources moderates take
about 60% liberal sources about 30 to
40% conservative sources and
conservatives it's inverted about 60 per
60 70 % conservative and 30% liberal
yeah conservatives do read left-wing new
sites and liberal new sources yeah so
they've seen the fake news then they see
the correction and they go there it is
the left doesn't they see the fake news
and then they walk away yeah and they
never learn the truth that's all I
needed
yeah now I can go complain to everybody
yeah well you saw what I was talking
about earlier today with Trump owning a
stake in that pharmaceutical companies
yeah right man this is so even 90 bucks
heard some $99 $99 I mean it could
potentially be higher than that
sure like MarketWatch did a fair take
saying well actually it's let's give you
the context I wake up this morning and
I'm scrolling down the Twitter's and I
and I pull up the reddit's and then
they're over on good old are slash
politics
which is supposed to be a place for
normal discourse the top post Donald
Trump owns steak and pharmaceutical
company that manufactures
hydroxychloroquine and so in the
comments they're all like I knew it The
Daily Beast says there it is there it is
it's like we got him boys
busted now we know why Trump is
promoting this drug and then sure enough
even even never Trump or George Conway
like he hates Trump yeah
tweeted like oh come on it's a minority
stake through a mutual fund this is
ridiculous yeah
and I'm like you know the media become
has become so desperate with their lies
trying to you know push back and
whatever they can Donald Trump's family
has multiple trusts mmm one of them has
a stake in a mutual fund okay which has
3.3% holdings in a company called like
Santa Phil or something widget so it's
like a stake of a stake it's not even
like an actual right stake and that's
why they were saying it might be like it
could be as low as $99 like oh that's
trumps big play billionaire Donald Trump
impeachment again people people already
call for it I know they will say already
were I'm glad to see so so anyway it's
it's basically a mutual fund has a stake
in this company it's like 3% and so
there are other funds that Trump does
have which means his stake could be a
bit higher maybe like 1,500 bucks it's
like so what are you said a joke like
Trump invested a thousand bucks in this
company the one on TV and promoted it
why so we can make so we can get a 10%
return to make a hundred bucks it's
ridiculous
you know but but that's why I wonder if
it's the media's fault for not vetting
this yeah they see a viral Instagram
post and they're like run it and it's
like do you know who she has who cares
who cares she had a lot of hits yup yeah
that's what they want you know you want
to know what's a really messed up thing
about media is I guess if I if I put it
a video right now that was titled like
proof Hillary Clinton is a lizard and
turns into a lizard on camera and it got
a million views yeah I make money on a
million views okay and then the next day
I make a video saying my bad I was wrong
about that yeah it gets 30,000 views I
make money on that thirty thousand views
not only do they make money on the lie
they make money on the retraction so
they're totally
sent device to do this yeah good point
now like I was saying you know these
like lefty types will they'll watch CBS
and they'll walk away so these people
are now actually believing I'm willing
to bet you go talk to any one of your
friends citizen really pay attention
there anybody look didn't trope like own
the company that was making that drug
and you're gonna deal with every day
yeah and then to get the likes well it's
money well the likes equal money I mean
like you know when Huffington Post wrote
about it they get you know 150 150 five
hundred thousand shares or views or
whatever on the article yeah they made
the money already then a day later they
can put correction the story was fake it
doesn't matter they made the money they
don't got to give it back boom so here's
what ends up happening I do these videos
where I'm like it's not true Trump
doesn't own the stake and then they're
like why are you defending Trump it's
like uh no I'm not defending Trump I'm
criticizing the media for lying yeah
there's a really funny skit called stop
making me defend Trump have you seen it
no I haven't I think you told me about
it yeah we the internet TV oh yeah it's
really good yeah it's like it's like a
guys like an office okay and these two
people are saying in saying things about
Trump and he's like he turns right like
I don't think that's true and they're
like why are you defending Trump bro you
Trump supporters like no I just don't
think that's true and they're like yo
big it but I start yelling at him yeah
that's how it goes it's how it feels
yeah so the funny thing is to like CBS
CBS here's why I think it's CBS s fault
I don't trust him man mm-hmm
III think I don't trust them either
they're given the opportunity to verify
this woman and in fact check whether or
not she's telling the truth before they
right run instead they're deciding to
run it don't worry up there look she's
crying that's juicy we'll get lots of
hits you're on it all the pornos like
but they recently used footage from an
Italian hospital claiming it was New
York right yeah so silly I mean many of
you have probably already seen this
because it was a just over a week ago
yeah I how do they think they're gonna
get away with this
you know I guess too many people it's
funny when they rag on Fox News for
having like old viewers because Fox News
actually has more key demographic
viewers
and the other other networks like CBS mm
uh like MSNBC in CNN okay and and so I
think what's really happening is these
these networks that have older viewers
it does to a decent extent include Fox
News they're never going to correct this
on-air
CBS issues like a tiny like note on
their website
oops or on their Twitter message like
you said yeah we're good recovered yep
that should do it man it's it's crazy
went out like I'm at like I was at
Walgreens and the lady at the counter
the cashier we are walking up and they
have all the social distancing stuff
everywhere mm-hmm and she said something
that was just so insane about like Trump
and his son and she's like wow you know
the president's doing these things and
I'm like like it would take me so long
to unwind all of these like what's what
spawned the the comment what did she
just like blurt it out yeah just yeah
yeah you walked up oh hello
yeah so residence doing this like
seriously yes so it's so quiet so
they're doing the social distancing
stuff uh-huh and then it started with
something like that hand sanitizer okay
and then I'm like oh you got some hand
sanitizer and she's like yup well we got
to do what we can because I'm like you
know the president I'm like that you
know I'm serious and I'm just like and
then it's it's it wasn't exactly that
direct but it needs me I've already
checked out of this conversation I would
like to pay for my goods yeah I just I
just want Ben & Jerry's it's this
chocolate with in the middle and I don't
want to talk about this right now
talk about salty I want to go home no it
wasn't it wasn't that quick but it was
like within the span of 30 seconds it
went from like yeah I I actually don't
think it's that crazy that we're talking
about coronavirus the pandemic all the
things they're doing and the president
comes up yeah but I can't member exactly
what she said but I was just like then
it's just it's like a lie layered upon
lie you know what it is it's it's thirst
it's people being thirsty it's gross I
can't stand it it's like all I see is
just all these thirsty people like the
influencers they're just thirsty for
attention the media thirsty for that
money really make the CEOs are thirsty
for that profit thirsty for attention
the people who are addicted to attention
it's like man y'all gotta calm down
I have and learn it what it is to be
human again III rampant but you know I
am I am excited about getting banned
from all social platforms finally just
break the chain let me get my van go
fishing man let me leave down by the
river down by the river in the van
get a dog or something and just man I
see these photos of these van life
influencers yes I wanted to be able to
take the show on the road but it's
really not possible and that's why we
ended up doing this instead yeah but hey
man you you you want to come and ban me
off this hate hold on hold on sorry
sorry please don't ban us yeah I really
like my job it's great so yeah hey III I
don't listen am I really know it's like
it's like it for me it's not about it's
really funny when they're like oh all
Tim wants is attention and all the stuff
it's like no no I just please know it's
a passion thing it's an obligation thing
it's like I see something and I'm like I
really want to talk about it
yeah and there's so much I want to talk
about yeah you vent like nobody else the
X I'm reading your champion venture
right and it's it's enlightening
actually but listening to your opinions
on things cuz their I'm a logical based
person so I respect logic a lot and you
are very logical so when you analyze the
news and the media and the things that
are going on it makes sense from a logic
you know point and it's I appreciate
that a lot I think when I'm sure that's
why people like watching you too but
yeah reason what I think a lot of people
don't realize as well is that I don't
see me doing the stuff but I mean yeah I
read the news and I feel this way and
then I complain about it but then you
know I act it though for the most part
well I don't I don't watch Hannity and I
don't watch for the most part Rachel I
don't I watch Hannity periodically for
like relevant things i watch Rachel
Maddow periodically for relevant things
okay and so I just see them and I talk
about what I like or don't like but
there are a lot of people who actually
watch a lot of it and then when I see
comments or people saying like Oh Tim
you do it better I don't understand what
they mean because I don't watch myself
right oh no I just taught you you mean
you know yeah you're just doing you
that's the great but but away from me
the point is this this nurse lady all
right she I want to keep talking about
you no no that's fine let's go no but
she's a perfect example of what you're
saying exactly
I know and it turns out she was trying
to be an influencer right and she went
back for one day and made a fake video
like duh hello this is doing it hits
some some reporter I love it I you know
why people like Trump so much not this
is one reason when he rags on the press
yeah the the press doesn't understand
how good that makes people feel true
they just watched that clip where the
journalist is like I want to ask you
about oil prices and he goes where's it
where's it at right now and then the guy
goes well my question is no no what's
the price I don't know I'm gonna do
research on that and he's like okay next
I've been oh man I've been in these
press junket kind of things yeah where
like you know I was in Chicago they did
some big arrests it's like a big
activist thing the police chief walks up
and then I'm sitting there and I'm just
like hmm interesting and the journalists
are desperately trying to think of
something to ask yeah like me even if
anything even if it's irrelevant yeah
and then and then you'll hear it because
everyone's yelling questions right and
sometimes people yell things you're like
what did you just say because they're
don't know what to say and they know if
they don't have a question they're not
getting a chance to ask did you just ask
what color socks these were ha ha no but
it's like almost like listening a bunch
of Joe Biden's yeah words are coming out
but what your question was was
completely nonsensical and then it's
because the way it works is all the
journalists will yell and the guy will
go and then point at somebody right and
then they'll ask a question but there
are so many journalists I've watched
where they're like they ask the
stupidest questions because they feel
like they have to sometimes there's
nothing to ask man sometimes just good
just move on you know but it's it's it's
it's similar so here's a guy at a press
briefing doesn't know what the current
price of oil is but wanted to ask about
the current price of oil he would you
would understand the question the answer
if he gave it to you yeah exactly
that's that's what Trump was like what
am i I'm wasting my time with you I love
the next I love it yes it was like he
was like well I'll look into it later is
like no okay how you gonna ask a
question yeah I think he said something
like that yes it was pretty funny it was
funny too when he called out the the
Chinese propaganda report dude I was
looking
and the owner of the company she works
for was a member of the CCP right yeah
and I was like are you a private no yeah
I know it's not no it's not yeah mm-hmm
anyway as much as a we've set at fifty
billion and one x media lies people are
it you know I look at it like kind of
like a toilet swirling around making its
way to the to the to the end point I
don't know if I like this analogy all of
these so the media is literal mmm like
verbal diarrhea free yes debris yes
spinning around getting faster and
faster and faster as it makes it way to
the ultimate endpoint of just like just
wiping itself out but these like these
social media influencers in the media
they're doing the exact same things they
chase after one-upping each other so
that's why you end up seeing these weird
wouldn't it cause it to overflow though
knowing it down
it's just flushing too much yeah I view
it kind of like a you know to get away
from the toilet algae like a whirlpool
no that's slowly spinning faster and
faster and it actually shuts ejecting
people right so so imagine you're a
regular person caught in this you know
whirlpool and you're reading all this
fake news I'm still still envisioning a
toilet you're in the toilet but
eventually you start spitting so fast
you don't have it thrown out I'd be
grateful I'm out of that toilet well
this is where like I think Alyssa Milano
has it has carried people okay so she's
tweeting right now like the Bernie
supporters in the Trump supporters all
sound the same it's like wow everyone
hates you yeah like maybe you should
realize that you that mean everyone who
did it right who do you think you're
talking to
she's uniting everyone like well the
Biden supporters are like yeah yeah yeah
right all for Biden supporters let's
look how many people are talking about
Alyssa Milano still that's my point
she's doing it for attention yeah that's
it and it worked
yep yep maybe that's why she did it
maybe she maybe she knew that it would
be the attention she needs no one's been
talking about me for a while
yep and and she doesn't care about
Bernie or Biden supporters the
establishment
I'm sorry Bernie or Trump supporters the
establishment wants Biden and she knows
it so she knows he'll go to Hollywood
there's gonna be some super rich
you know Democrat guys gonna be like I
don't care good Biden ya know socialism
for me like I'm not I'm not a big fan of
Bernie for a lot of reasons I was before
but not so much as I you know today for
well he's not the same he's not the same
and it's fine it's funny to see people
like Rogan say like he's so consistent
I'm like nah he was he was consistent
until 27 and then he started chasing
after a wolf stupid idiot in 2016 then
it was like but he's been changed in
2016 man yeah yeah he used to fight for
working class people like labor unions
and all sudden he gets up on stage in
2016 and said if you're white you don't
know it's like to be poor I tell people
that no like he never said that I'm like
dude he said it he said if you're white
you don't know what it's like to be poor
that I could see it poor most white
people in this country are poor majority
of poor people are white I could see it
in his face he knew he was lying because
he was definitely trying to pander to
these weird elitist activists yeah and I
was like nah and then he flipped up on
guns and he flipped up on immigration
but anyway the point is you won't have
an argument about policy I'm totally
down here here's my points about Bernie
Sanders that I don't like I've talked
about Trump in foreign policy Joe Biden
can't talk I know you're it's it's
insane there's nothing there yeah that's
a joke thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you